CROWD: GOOD MORNING HANK
[PEOPLE SHOUTING] It's Monday! JOHN: I think it's--I think it's Tuesday. I think it's gonna be Tuesday.
Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday, some day at the end of October and
you just got said hello to by a bunch of extremely excited nerdfighters in Phoenix, Arizona
who are only able to say hello to you because of my awesome new camcorder!
I am so excited about my new camcorder here Hank, let me show it to you.
Oh, oh wait, if I move the camcorder... I'm just gonna.. [MUMBLING]
I'm just gonna take a picture of the camcorder using the camcorder--DANG IT!!
[INTRO MUSIC]
Okay Hank so you might remember, in my last video I asked the nerdfighters what I could do for them
after they did all this awesome stuff for me,
including getting Paper Towns on the New York Times Best Seller list
and it turns out that the nerdfighters do indeed have some requests
''I think you should do NaNoWriMo in November, which is national novel writing month!''
Unfortunately, despite getting down on my knees every night and
praying that God turn me into James Patterson, I'm not able to write a novel in a month.
However, in the month of November I am considering national
'finish-your-revision-of-your-book-I-mean-seriously-come-on' month, also known as NaFRBIMSCON.
The only problem with that is that November is also national 'drive-around-America-with-your-brother' month
or NaDaAWiBMo
So I'm definitely gonna do NaDaAWiBMo and I'm gonna try to do NaFRBIMSCON
and I apologise in advance that it's gonna be totally impossible to do NaNoWriMo.
''Make sure when they make a movie of Paper Towns they don't ruin it!''
Um, okay, you're not gonna like the way I respond to that request.
Uh, first, I don't  think that they can ruin a book with a movie.
Like, no matter how unconvincing Sean Penn's Louisiana accent sounds,
All the King' Menace is still a great book.
Also I ascribe to the belief that in order to properly adapt a book into a film
you have to radically change, like, everything about the book. Sorry.
Perfecter Chemistry says:
''You can repay us by promoting literature online and also in schools everywhere!''
It's funny you should bring that up, Perfecter Chemistry,
so Hank today I was in a high school in Seattle, trying to get the kids excited about reading,
talking about books and why they still matter and blah blah blah,
and um, pretty much during my entire presentation, there was a lot of, like, laughter,
and I didn't know what exactly they were laughing at, I was like 'I guess I am just one funny guy'
and then about forty-five minutes into my one hour talk I opened it up for questions and, like, thirty hands shot up,
which is a little bit unusual so I called on someone and they were like
''Um, yes, Mr Green,
are you aware of the fact that your zipper is like, flagrantly, almost obscenely unzipped?''
AAAAAAH NO I DIDN'T BUT I DID HANK!
I gave my entire speech about the importance of imagining other people complexely
with, like a massively unzipped zipper.
''Can you just, like, give me a hug? You're just like a giant teddy bear, and I just love you.''
Did you have to say that I'm like a giant teddy bear? Couldn't you have just said that I'm like a regular teddy bear?
Look, I know that the Weight Watchers hasn't gone well, you try eating on the road, it hard out here for a touring author!
''It would be awesome if you went on a national campaign to make skydiving legal for minors.''
[LAUGHS] I mean, Hank, knowing what you do about me,
can you imagine a campaign that I am less likely to go on?
I don't think skydiving should be legal for anyone!
It's crazy! You shouldn't jump out of a plane, planes are for staying in!
''Make my Walmart get Paper Towns!''
It's actually an exceptionally bad idea to buy your books at Walmart,
because if everyone buys their books at Walmart then
we're looking at a future when about thirty to fifty books will be published each year,
which will would have kind of a chilling effect on American cultural discourse,
plus it would put me out of a job because Walmart thinks my books are too dirty to stock.
So Hank it was starting to look like there was nothing the nerdfighters wanted me to do,
that I could do for them.
I mean, I can't do NaNoWriMo because I don't have time,
my conscience won't allow me to advocate for minors skydiving because I think it's a terrible idea,
and I can't get my books into Walmart because I'm too dirty!
But then finally, Hank, I saw a fulfillable request!
''Could you record yourself doing your happy dance for us in eighteen different states?''
YES. I. CAN!
My zipper is unzipped!
DANG IT!
Hank, I'll see you in just a few minutes at the amazing Seattle Public Library!